let's talk about the Qatar blockade the
football Gulf Cup is happening in Doha
and at first Saudi Arabia the UAE and
Bahrain said they were boycotting the
games but not anymore
they're sending teams and that's a big
deal because those Gulf nations broke
off ties with Qatar in 2017 they imposed
a land sea and air blockade that's still
in effect but let's rewind a second why
did these former allies fall out in the
first place
[Music]
let's start with some basic facts about
Gulf countries and generally we're
talking about six Arab states Saudi
Arabia Oman the United Arab Emirates
Qatar Bahrain and Kuwait
they're part of a political and economic
alliance called the Gulf Cooperation
Council or the GCC that was set up in
1981 and they have a lot in common
desert landscapes hot weather the Arabic
language Islam similar food and culture
and oil Gulf countries are also
relatively new their current borders
were only drawn up in the 20th century
the social fabric of these countries is
mainly based on tribes so you can find
people belonging to the same tribe let's
say for example living in Saudi Arabia
in Qatar and Bahrain and Emirates and
Kuwait because they used a sheet to move
freely and today's ruling families in
the Gulf come from these tribes the
al-thani and Qatar the House of Saud in
Saudi Arabia the ulna heun's in the UAE
the all-service in Kuwait the all Syed's
in Oman and the Khalifa's in Bahrain
many of these families intermarried so
they sort of have one foot in each
other's royal courts but one thing was
clear Saudi Arabia always saw itself in
the lead it's the largest and most
oil-rich Gulf country and it has Mecca
and Medina Islam's holiest sites and
Saudi Arabia's dominance in the GCC went
almost unchallenged until 1995
in Qatar Sheikh Hamad bin Khalifa
al-thani announced that he was taking
over power from his father and this Emir
had his own ideas about the path he
wanted for his country he decided
actually to is to have his own religion
international relations with the
original and international players he
decided to have a more balanced approach
in his foreign relations cutoff for
instance deepened its trading
relationship with Iran Saudis big rival
because they share a massive natural gas
reserve Qatar also launched a television
network called al-jazeera
and this isn't a plug it's actually a
very key part of the story you see while
Saudi Arabia had been dropping its
support for certain political Islamist
groups like the Muslim Brotherhood Qatar
didn't follow suit and Al Jazeera gave
the voices of political Islam and others
a platform the Saudis and the Amorites
they started to see the Muslim
Brotherhood as a major threat to them
why because for Saudi Arabia as a leader
of the Sunni Islam actually any other
form of Islamists or Islamic
organizations seen as a threat to the
leadership of the Muslim world
so Sheikh Hamad was seen as a bit of a
rebel there was even an attempted
overthrow of him in 1996 just a year
after he came to power which Saudi
Arabia the UAE and Bahrain all supported
but the coup failed so as you can
imagine that created even more tension
and then came the Arab Spring a wave of
uprisings in Tunisia Egypt Syria Yemen
and Bahrain saw people take to the
streets to overthrow authoritarian
leaders
and Cathars al Jazeera media network
covered at all the deadly nationwide
crackdown has attracted international
condemnation the Saudis actually not
like that a lot because they were really
concerned that that wave of Arab Spring
might just come to the to their Shores
especially after the collapse of Hosni
Mubarak regime in Egypt what happened in
Egypt after the Arab Spring really made
Saudis leaders nervous and this is just
one place and one example of how the
split with Qatar widened even further
Egypt held its first democratic election
in 2012 won by Mohamed Morsi who was
backed by the Muslim Brotherhood a year
later after Pro and anti Morsi protests
the military forced him out what
followed was a violent clampdown that
killed hundreds of his supporters an Al
Jazeera covered that to everyone in the
square including journalists covering
the protests came under a hail of
apparently indiscriminate gunfire this
was a team from al jazeera Qatar
meanwhile welcomed Muslim Brotherhood
members who fled people that Egypt's
military leaders called terrorists so
leaders in the GCC started to think cuts
are had gone rogue those countries broke
off diplomatic ties in 2014 and they
wanted the u.s. to back them up the
Saudis were really best off by the Obama
administration foreign policy towards
the region Obama was mainly occupied
with negotiation with Iran over its
nuclear program and he was less
sensitive to the concerns
of the Saudis but when Donald Trump
entered the White House things changed
when Trump actually came to power in
2017 the Saudis the Emiratis the
Pyrenees and Egyptians who already had
problems with Qatar because of the Arab
Spring and because of Qatar foreign
relations and then decided actually to
take it to the very end what cut out
this time in other words the GCC's main
players said it's time to do something
about Qatar so on June 5th 2017 Saudi
Arabia the UAE Bahrain and Egypt imposed
a blockade
note that Oman and Kuwait didn't take
part air sea and land routes were
suddenly closed off trade and goods like
dairy were bent and Saudi Arabia even
expelled Qatari camels but more
importantly Qatari citizens were kicked
out of those blockading countries and
thousands of families were broken up the
pound or so lost we may like you know be
separated from our children and return
back to Bahrain a lot of families are
integrated between different countries
from the Gulf region why should we be
separated because of politics
the blockading countries also presented
a list of demands
some of the big ones were that Qatar
downgrade diplomatic ties with Iran shut
down al Jazeera altogether and cut ties
to so-called terrorist groups we have
taken this step with great pain in order
to make sure that Qatar understands that
these policies are not acceptable and
not sustainable that they must change
but cuddler maintained that it didn't
support terrorism and refused to budge
on their demands
we believe that mainly the main issue is
not is not about terrorism the main
issue is opposing the process and the
way to shut the other voice and maybe
they are looking at what are that it's
punishing oversweet the blockade did
initially impact
tarz economy but it did bounce back
after Qatar took steps like shoring up
its banks trading more with Iran and
Turkey and manufacturing its own
products to avoid relying on imports so
with Qatar doing its thing and the
blockading countries refusing to lift
the embargo there have been few signs of
a breakthrough but some suspect that
with a Gulf Cup going ahead as normal
these former allies might slowly be
opening up to the idea of playing nice
[Music]
thanks for watching and sending us your
ideas for future start here episodes our
team is already working on them but do
keep sharing their thoughts questions
and comments on Twitter YouTube and
Facebook we love hearing from you